- Here are the nominees for
achievement in directing.
- We're just a few very busy months away
from the Academy Awards
so it's probably a good time
to start making some
early Oscar predictions,
am I right?
This is what we do with our free time.
We're gonna tell you which directors
we think may snag an
Oscar nomination right now
on the Ketchup.
There are some huge
names on our early list,
starting with Quentin Tarantino
and his ninth studio film,
Once Upon a Time in Hollywood,
which is certified fresh
at 85% on the tomato meter.
After a somewhat mediocre response
to his last effort in
2015's The Hateful Eight,
Tarantino enlisted the help
of some guys named Leo
and Brad this time around
and they gave two of the most
universally acclaimed
performances of the year.
Still can't believe this was
their first film together.
- It's official, old buddy.
I'm a has-been.
- Tarantino will live to get
his third Oscar nomination
and first win in the directing category,
having previously been nominated
for 1994's Pulp Fiction
and 2009's Inglorious Bastards,
both certified fresh, by the way.
- I'm the one who buys
it, I know how good it is.
- Someone else who knows
a little bit about being nominated
is the iconic Martin Scorsese.
The 76-year-old director is back
with Netflix's The Irishman
and yes, there's a theme here.
This film is loaded with huge names,
like Robert De Niro,
Al Pacino, Joe Pesci, and Harvey Keitel.
- Hiya Frank, this is Jimmy Hoffa.
- After five nominations,
2006 certified fresh The Departed
gave Marty his first
directing win after 25 years.
So I guess the pressure's off,
but with a little help from his friends
Bob, Al, and Joe,
not to mention new state-of-the-art
de-aging technology,
it's like Scorsese's just getting started.
- Where are you going?
- I'm going to work.
- Greta Gerwig has also made this list
for her upcoming
adaptation of Little Women,
starring Timothee Chalamet,
Saoirse Ronan, Emma
Watson, and Meryl Streep.
I mean the casting crew combined
is nearly 35 Oscar nominations.
- You are not married--
- Well,
that's because I'm rich.
- And Greta is coming off
a directing nomination
from 2018's Oscars for Lady Bird.
This time Gerwig is
adapting a popular story
that has done well at
the Oscars in the past,
including a best picture
win for 1949's version
of Little Women, with Elizabeth Taylor,
so the odds of being nominated
could be in her favor.
Next up is James Mangold
from the true life tale, Ford V Ferrari.
Currently fresh at 89%
on the tomato meter.
Much like Taratino, Mangold
had a couple of megstars
of his own to work with: Matt
Damon and Christian Bale.
- Looks aren't everything.
- But when it comes to the Oscars,
Mangold has directed
both Reese Witherspoon
to a best actress win
for 2005's Walk the Line,
and Angelina Jolie to a
best supporting actress win
for 1999's Girl Interrupted,
but his only nomination
came in the adapted screenplay category
for 2017's Logan.
So now seems like the perfect time
for him to join the best director race.
Let's just hope he's a Ford in this case.
(laughing)
And finally rounding out the fifth spot
in our early predictions
is South Korean director Bong Joon Ho,
whose film Parasite is
a certified fresh 100%
on the tomato meter.
The social political satire
which explores the evils
of wealth, inequality,
and class discrimination
earned the top prize
at the Cannes film festival.
And while he may not have
a who's who of a cast
like the other directors
that we just mentioned,
the Rotten Tomatoes critics consensus
is that Parasite shows a director
quote in near total command of his craft.
And since Alfonso Cuaron just
became the first director
of a foreign language film
to win the best director
Oscar for last year's Roma,
why not Bong Joon Ho this year?
(speaking in foreign language)
So I wanna kick it over to you guys now.
Which of these directors
do you think has the best chance
to take home the Oscar?
Are there any names that we left off
that you feel are more deserving?
And can the director of
a foreign language film
win two years in a row?
Let us know all your thoughts and feelings
in the comments section,
and for more movie news,
head on over to rottentomatoes.com.
As always, thanks for
watching The Ketchup.
I'm Naz Perez, and I'll
see you guys next time.